do
what is up everyone welcome to gamespot
live happy monday
persia here and today we are playing
fall guys with the one and only star
smitten how's it going
it's going good i'm i'm good
awesome and for everyone tuning in
today's stream is sponsored by verizon
with super fast 5g
and super low latency you can lag less
and play more
if you want to learn more then you can
visit verizon.com
gaming alright speaking of gaming let's
play
some fall guys to be honest it's been a
while since i've played i don't know
about
you star smitten but i'm excited to pop
in
it's definitely been a while but it's
okay
i'm excited i'm excited yeah like season
three
you know we're doing the main show
i this is my first hop into season three
actually so
all the new stuff today
but happy mother's day together
did you have a good weekend yeah yeah i
did
awesome i didn't even realize the
weekend was over what date what day is
it today's
monday i mean all the days just mixed
together at this point
i don't know because the quarantine i
actually cannot teleport what day it is
ever yeah i've been thinking about
getting a giant calendar to like put on
the walls
just so it's always in front of my face
so i can remember
sometimes
but yeah everyone in the chat thank you
so much for tuning in
everyone's super excited to see you here
with us today
star smitten i'm excited too
and we need three more people to
populate our game
if you guys at home are playing you
should try to search at the same time as
this
see if you can get into our game
all right oh my gosh ah it's been so
long
i'm excited oh this is a game i've done
before have they added new games
i believe so oh wait no it looks a
little different
oh it looks kind of different actually
oh my god i don't i don't even remember
how to play
i'm just going to hold forward look at
all those santa
outfits look at all the clothes
that's okay okay okay okay okay
oh my god where are you i don't see you
ow i know isn't it supposed to put in oh
i think i see yours now
oh please don't fall up please
oh my god okay we're professionals we've
got this
[Music]
when did this game get so hard everyone
just got so good
oh my god this game goes so freaking
hard oh my god am i even gonna make it
through this part i don't know i don't
know oh my god
that that that that should not have hit
me that should not have me either
oh my god
okay okay i'm here i'm here there's no
way oh my god i'm not gonna make it am i
i barely need it okay
no that's my first game of the day okay
it's it's button checks
it was all button checks you know i'm
just warming up oh my god that was the
hardest thing
first game of the day guys all button
checks
oh my god that snowman outfit is so cute
ah all the christmas stuff is actually
so cute
there's just something about christmas
right all of the
all the skins all the content okay
persia carry us
through oh my gosh i'm i'm knocked out
i'ma just watch your perspective
[Laughter]
i just don't want any team games a true
team games kind of suck early
oh this is what is this oh it's so cute
it's all like snow flaky all right we're
going
skiing skiing yeah oh my god this is so
cute
all right you gotta coach me i i got
knocked out that first
and oh no okay i'm back now
[Music]
no you know this one this one was hard
i'm not gonna lie
oh my oh they tried
watching
[Applause]
i believe in my unicorn friend here
it looked too tall
it's fine let's just no no
no i like how the goals
that three of 15 right now
okay you know what i mean slow and
steady wins the race
right hey don't bump into me people kill
don't pump it
okay
this one looks hard the first jump i did
was probably the best
no okay no you're okay you're okay oh i
finally got through the first
okay but only four qualified so there's
that
okay i'm gonna exit to the main menu
same i don't wanna see the abuse of my
my little character there all right
warm-ups guys
warm up warm enough just warm you know
how it is
it's winter time it's cold the hands are
chilly
all right so what are some of your
favorite levels in this besides the one
you haven't seen yet or the ones you
haven't played yet
i don't remember what they're called but
i like all the ones that require just
like jump timings
i like those yes like the little hexagon
one i think yeah i like the thicker one
i like the one where like it's just like
spinning around and you just like
hop over the little thing that like
knocks you out
like i like things like that
i think those are my favorites any
anything that's like jump
mechanic e okay what about
what about the one where they flash the
fruit on the screen you have to guess
which oh my god or you have to remember
what i was good at
i was good at that and then like at some
point i stopped being good at that i
don't know what happened
my brain just started being like okay
this one's unfun i'm like kicking this
out of your like
memory library and like you're gonna be
bad at it now
i don't like this one either oh you just
have to like stay
kind of in the middle and let someone
else take the lead
unless your rng is absolutely insane
and you guys go through everything but
my rng is terrible so
fain i'ma just follow someone
all right we got this oh what's that
thing at the end is that
i don't know oh my god look at all the
new skins and i
i i am so obviously from season one
[Laughter]
i'm all the way in the back all right oh
i see you over there
okay okay we got this somebody else
somebody else somebody else okay okay
nice like almost all of them were i'm
following the ninja okay don't follow
the ninja don't follow the ninja
follow the blue waves okay don't follow
the blue dude
okay oh oh hello oh
no we're right next to each other yeah
okay we got this we got this okay
okay far right oh no oh no we are
funneling now i keep
losing sight of my little guy oh
oh my god there's so many people this is
him
this is not social distancing no no no
no
right the crowd goes right the crap
oh my god oh my god that's what that's
for
honestly i can see that being helpful oh
my god we made it
oh my goodness
oh my goodness thank god i got the first
round this time
oh look at all those reindeer skins too
all right on to the next round i'm
feeling good about this round you know
one warm up
that's all we needed
oh this one oh what oh snap fall again
all right you've learned from my
mistakes now
take us to victory oh my god okay i've
learned slow and steady
is is the way to win this one right
i i mean clearly i figured out
absolutely nothing
in my room so take two i can't believe
only 15 make it through
for this
oh my god okay
[Music]
okay hold on okay
stop it guys i need to go back up and
get momentum
yep okay i've made a mistake
[Laughter]
[Music]
like can i just oh my god oh my god
do i have to go through these rings yeah
i think so
okay because i definitely just went
through the side like twice
oh oh yeah yep yep yep yep you can't
oh my god this one's so hard oh my god
okay please don't please don't ah
that's so hilarious though oh no
the three people who got through this
man kudos you guys are the best gamer in
life
[Music]
i was so close
please no okay okay
i made it into the second ring and not
the center ring i'm so sad
is this is this level gonna be the bane
of our existence
i actually think so
i think so rest in pieces
holy moly i definitely did not even get
past that second
i got in the second ring but not the
bullseye
how do you get in the bullseye you need
some
real momentum or something i know
okay it's okay it's whatever i believe
in us
back to the drawing board you know we're
gonna stew on this loss
you know l is not for loss it's for
lesson and we learned a lot right there
okay
okay okay again
again again run it back
oh my goodness we'll get it we'll get
through that level at least once today
or you know we don't get to live at all
and then it saves us something i'm
getting it who knows
we'll see yeah maybe we can avoid it all
together
um for everyone tuning in we are
watching from star smitten's pov
oh yeah you guys are watching my
perspective i'm sorry
i'm sure they would prefer to watch your
pod no so don't feel bad
um if you do end up watching mine it'll
be
like if i'm still in and and
starsmitton's watching my tv but
for the most of it it should be yours so
all right here we go here we go
dizzy heights okay okay i think i can
manage i remember this one
i think i remember this one
are you still in the waiting for player
screen i am okay there we go it just
started
i was like let me run
well where am i oh oh my gosh
oh why can't i i can't here we go
right it's fine we'll just go with the
motions
oh my god of course
hey i'm probably not gonna make it
through this
i know they're so rude
ow oh okay okay that that sucked
okay i see get out of my way ninja
i got places to be okay down here sucks
oh god there's no way i'm making this am
i
i believe they kind of changed every
level a little bit
just good keeping it fresh
oh yeah i totally just walked straight
off map like the smartest gamer either
oh yes
there you go okay i get to watch your
perspective now oh you're almost there
i'm trying no no
it's fine you got this bring the team
across
i let my guy fall rest in peace
look at all these ninjas in here i know
there's so many
there's literally like 10 ninjas i was
like whoa
[Laughter]
oh my god okay i will figure this out i
i i swear
i want him i want to make it through
this
i feel like it wants you to be right in
the center
almost every time so i forgot third one
oh i haven't even been there yet don't
even know
chat says celine is on fire you've got
this
what do you mean
[Laughter]
oh you can go through stop stop stop
stop i was ready
okay okay this one this one i
just freaking
okay great nice oh cleared it
nice safe okay
okay okay all right let me just you know
okay
all right you're like i need some more
bouncy things
hey smooth he got this
nice save no
that wasn't your fault everybody got in
your way
okay okay okay okay okay calculated
okay nice okay okay okay here we go
[Music]
okay okay that was
it that was it
oh my goodness okay i just have to jump
it's fine you've gotten further than
both of us so
next time you're definitely in there
so close i'm so sad
i was i'm so sad i was so close
okay it's okay the next time the third
time
the third time i come across i'll get
through it that one's so good third
time's the charm
what a jam what a gem
i love walker's music
it's so it just makes my shoulders like
uncontrollably
like do this it's not me much the song
is doing this
it's really cheerful
all right here we go we got this i
wonder how they changed this one up
i like how they make it all nice and
bright and colorful and cheery but it's
certain like miserable death incoming
trying to fight for our lives
oh
oh wait how do you climb i forget oh my
gosh there's so many people here
stop it guys i can't believe that just
happened to me
i'm gonna be stuck here forever okay
okay
i'm really bad about the timing stuff
you know i take it back i don't like any
of the timing stuff
don't don't get out the worst thing
happened to me okay i hope you made it
through because i
am definitely not qualified there's just
i'm not there yet
there's just no way i'm qualified
there's just no way
hey only one person has qualified so far
i believe
oh my god we have time
oh wow nice don't you let me just run
off without even jumping
oh yes i've done that my favorite
yeah get out of the way i
oh my gosh i might make it no gatekeeper
state get away from me santa no
okay we're good oh my god this poor guy
he doesn't know how to get up no
it's okay buddy honestly i don't either
i just jumped on the yellow square
oh he looks so sad and defeated
we made it success
are they going to give us this ski one
again
you know what i hope so because i i want
to be able to
achieve it at least once exactly run it
back
give it to me give me the ski fall one
okay oh okay okay i mean it's been
second race like every time maybe it's
just a second race type of thing
i got this oh i see there's big fans on
the ones on the left and
right all right let me try and get into
this
oh my how sad
all right i see people cheating so i'm
gonna try to cheat too
all right run on the side oh you can run
on the side
and see if it requires you to
oh my gosh you made it no i almost did
though
i and but i don't know if it's gonna
count if i'm cheating right now
imagine you just get there by doing this
and they're like sorry
no no they would if you make it you make
it no matter how you do it
in this game i swear freaking like that
oh
[Music]
come on
oh that's what i get why is that simple
i didn't even exist
what do you mean i was gonna make
that's gonna be my goal today my goal is
getting through this ski
jump one i
i refuse
i refuse to let that ski jump one be
the stopping point but they did make
this game a lot harder
oh my god i know i have the [ __ ] like
channel platforming skills that i don't
have right now
too ascend yeah i've been playing
i've been playing so many games and this
is the hardest game i've played this
week
what oh my god
i mean i've never won a [ __ ] a game in
this yet
so in ball guys yes i haven't
i need to win one honestly it just means
you haven't played enough because i
think you play enough you eventually
wouldn't win
true true you just have to play
a lot
i don't think you need to make it into
the middle you just need 15 points
oh interesting
[Laughter]
thanks chat we would have never
figured this out i was wondering what
the out of 15 was
oh my god that makes so much sense i
actually would have never figured that
out
oh this one okay this one's a real test
of your patience
like are you going to stand here and
wait for the seesaw to
turn the other way oh yeah i remember
this one this one
wow they haven't changed this one at all
this one's like the only one that they
haven't changed
[Music]
oh my goodness
bring it down
oh this is not good no
let's go let's go
shhh
okay okay
whoa was that lag never slide
looks like some people in this server
needs to get some verizon 5g
all right that was like that was a great
ah
let's go home you can kill yourself no
no no no no
come on
oh my god i thought that was the end of
the level i still have a whole another
section to go through oh my god oh i see
you
oh my god we're in this
[Music]
come on work with us work with us people
bring them
oh i caught you oh my god
oh lordy let's go
score i barely
my god look at how many people didn't
get in
inferior you are better than them
it's gonna be ski fall again i know it
right
well now now you know how to qualify so
yes
15 points easy
knowledge is you know power knowing's
half of that
all that gets oh ew
i like this one actually this one's
pretty fun
i wonder if they changed it up
oh there's like a scenery now
oh yeah nice
whoa this lag is gonna kill me before
anything else does
maybe too many people are playing today
now they're in the holiday spirit
okay okay don't grab me please
freaking
[Laughter]
please please okay okay all right
looking good looking good
nice nice social distancing you got here
nice
chill guys chill chill
chill can get oh this is nice this is
nice this is nice okay
to the other one
okay we're good
nice save okay okay we could we could
please do not grab me you know let's
have a truce
we're all just trying to survive yeah
we're all just trying to survive
together
why can't everyone just you know get
along
let's cooperate please the servers are
lagging
and everything you know okay to the next
one
yes see this uh this platform here this
is the way to go
this is nice oh my god
easy easy
when the ski one isn't second easy yup
true
as long as this ski one isn't in my way
i can i can keep going
some things are just you know your
kryptonite
but yes chad if you're just joining us
today's stream is sponsored by verizon
super fast 5g and super low latency you
can lag less and play more
so if you want to learn more you can
visit verizon.com
gaming i think a couple people in this
server need to visit that website asap
so that they can stop lagging it up for
the rest of us
so we can get these crowns you know
people in their toaster computers
internet i guess
oh that banana costume is so funny the
back
oh i didn't even notice the like a
smiley face on it
that's pretty funny
let's all be nice guys let's be nice
guys
not just fall guys let's be nice guys
yeah
i'm just gonna dance in support of your
glorious victory that's inbound right
now
okay okay oh my god that banana skin i
can't i guess
[Laughter]
it's just smiling back at me i'm so
distracted i'm so distracted i can't
stop staring at it
it's just always looking at me
we can all make it through together in
this one
people just cooperate you know
tuesday a potato in the chat says i love
grabbing on
we're saying don't be mean
that is extremely mean we're just trying
to survive
okay guys we got this we got this you
got this
be nice okay please no so close 15
seconds
oh this way this way okay smart smart
smart smart okay back and forth back and
forth
we can all fit we can all feed look at
all that guys
i know don't be greedy guys there's room
for everyone
i got stuck on other people
that's all good again
one person in the front fell and then
it ruined it for everyone in literally
the last second
oh my goodness
i'm over it
[Laughter]
people don't be greedy
[Laughter]
all right we are we're hopping back in
we're starting it back up guys if you're
at home
and you want to play you should search
right now too but we can all play
together
true true
man that was so close
literally one second i was hoping like
your falling animation would take long
enough to drain out the seconds
but that would have been really nice
maybe i could have done something to do
that
i should have noticed that people were
like tripping in front of me
oh my goodness like everyone just saw
looked at the clock saw there was one
second and then brains just
simultaneously farted and everyone fell
off
that was it
except if you join us make sure you grab
everybody else except for us so that we
can get these
these dubs okay
oh god this one looks brutal it's got
like
axes and everything what's the heck
what happened to our friendly children's
game
i mean at least everything is like
seemingly made of rubber but like still
[Laughter]
all right here we go man those reindeer
costumes are super cute so
no i know i know what you mean oh this
is terrifying so
how do i do this one
let me know when you find out i keep
falling off already
no
oh i greeted oh my gosh celine just take
your time don't be greedy
i'm getting my character totally
murdered by
pointy swinging logs but we're fine
what
how am i supposed to do it
oh okay all right you're joking i made
it
oh my god you made it i'm yeah i'm yeah
oh you're so close
okay please please please please
no no no no no no
i'm so bad no timing stuff
i'm just so dead i can't i i i'm i'm
just
mad at this point and i refuse to stop
i i'm really bad at the timing things
because i get really angry and i just
like
force my way through and that's not
that's not very good
it's not very good i get it i get it
gabe i'm not supposed to do that but i
just get impatient you know i just get
really impatient
the pressure the game puts on you
towards the end no
i must get there right now
i don't even like this one cool i'm glad
to watch this from your perspective
i don't have the patience for like half
of the
i just don't oh
boy i know what's up
no okay that's fine yeah that's fine i'm
just gonna roll around
that part isn't even bad
no go with the flow yeah go with the
flow
you gotta follow traffic
follow follow follow-up let me know just
follow through yeah yeah yeah
and then don't get hit by these guys
okay okay okay it's okay you're still
you're still good
you're still fine oh my god that was so
clutch you're still
fine you're still good yeah just follow
the motion of the hammers let it
push you up a little okay it's okay it's
okay
it's okay look at that look at that look
at that
you are oh my god no no no you're gonna
qualify yeah it's all good it's not good
let's go
28 out of 30. i didn't even realize only
30 were supposed to make it oh my god
terrifying oh my god they have like a
sonic the hedgehog skin
i didn't even know
oh i see it on the bottom left
i've never seen that one before oh
snap i made it pretty far
you did
you're i feel like there's like this one
and
the next one might be finals no maybe
oh snap maybe a couple more
oh poopsy legends jump and dive through
hoops
to score six points oh boy
all righty then this is an individual
thing
oh it is an individual thing
oh people are going for the golden one
of course
yeah wait how do i climb again oh wait
there we go thing someone got up there
already
oh oh my god this one's calling for you
it is can i make it oh geez oh that's
actually he brushed it for you
oh yeah you're so sorry
oh no i didn't get it
um hi oh no okay there's one over there
go go for that one go for that one stop
it you go stop it you got it you
got it you got it you know what that guy
has insane
mechanics wow wait which what's dive
again i forget oh
x okay you've never dove this
time oh my god have you been making it
through
maybe i'm maybe i'm messing up because
i'm diving so much
no swimming spring get away no
um where's the next one spawning
not near me i guess oh no he was
waiting oh my god oh
oh no let's go
let's go no he's such a professional
yeah some of these people are kind of
crazy
they're insane there'll be one coming
over here soon when do people get so
good
this one's mine oh no that one's alone
you caught
all yeah all right there's gonna be
another one
coming soon oh gold one over there
no one's gonna spawn here i believe
oh i keep jumping too late
and just walking off the corner really
there hasn't been one to spawn over here
that guy didn't even go for that one he
psyched me out
wow there's two over there now
all right he didn't make it okay you got
this there's less people now and there's
more hoops
more hoops less people more hoops as
people okay more hoops
less people oh yeah yeah yeah
give me this
no all right i definitely did not
it was close it was close it was closed
that one's just you know
it's all it's all partly rng it's all
part i was hoping they would spawn near
me so i didn't have to run this
yeah that one you were in it didn't
spawn for a while
but it's fine it was so fun i hadn't
i've only done the team version of that
one actually
oh yeah yeah yeah same same same
the red blue and yellow team won
yeah and then nobody wants to be
on yellow tea i know what's up with that
haters i like how they were like
statistically
yellow team wins just as much as the
other two teams
why isn't that oh my gosh
man what a jam i can't get over it
all right show will start in one second
let's go i'm sure there's one person out
there who has this as their ringtone
oh absolutely or at least like a wake-up
alarm or something
it'd be a good alarm
hides again i think we did good on this
one
here we go
oh rude all of you
yeah this brings out the rudeness in
people
truly
all right diving is totally the tech
yeah i can't believe you've been making
it through without dying
it's like i saw someone do it and i was
like oh yeah
the thing all i do is dive in this game
okay watermelon you are in my face
yes okay phew
yeah we both made it we made it we made
it
see we're warming up now all right we
are
professionals yeah
i'm just like looking at all the skins
they've come out with so many
most of them cost crowns though right
like the special one
we're back okay now we know how to do
this oh yes yes yes yes
i'm assuming the gold ones are worth
more maybe yeah i don't know how you get
into the gold ones i got the center
true
i don't think i've seen anybody
all right here we go
oh my god people are pushing me okay
fine
i'm like here we go immediately falls
off
boom one point
no
oh i see okay okay okay i have two
points
that's it stop people
wait if you bounce backwards into it do
you get the point again
is that why they have that bounce back
pad
oh maybe that would be
are you serious ah
no oh my
lordy oh yeah maybe you're supposed to
like
bounce back into the gold one that's how
you get into the gold one too
okay for the life of me i can't get into
the gold one okay
it's all good okay i'm
at 12 i'm at 12. i'm i'm
you're so close
did you make it
i only had 9 out of 15. i had 13
but it was still not closed
but i do feel better about it knowing
same same true objective
and i would have never found out they're
true
if it wasn't for chat anyways so
like i'm happy with my knowledge gained
today
i've learned how to play that one
exactly
i'm pretty confident we'll qualify on
that one
stream i'm confident yeah hopefully
either of us reach the final round as
well before
this session
um that one's all on you okay okay
i got this i think
i totally got this is definitely
one of the hardest games i've ever
played
i've played a lot of games like a lot a
lot a lot of games
like the concept is simple but then you
throw like
60 other people on there then impossible
so hard it gets so freaking hard
i use a controller like on my pc when i
play this
i haven't seen anybody play like with
the mouse and keeper i tried with
massive keyboard at the beginning and it
was so hard
i just couldn't and i play a lot of
platformers actually with a
mouse and keyboard so i was like wow
this one this one you you just can't
you really really can't
oh gate crash this is a timing one too
and i just don't have the patience for
it but it's okay
i got it i got this
actually i guess everything in fall guys
is kind of a timing thing
true
i prefer the run timing than the jump
timing
personally oh no of course the second i
got to that one
oh wow okay thanks thanks level
oh what the best please
i was like does that one never open oh
my goodness
i definitely said the same exact thing
wow
crap oh this is going to be
no i hope you make it
[Laughter]
it's okay carrie has to pick me oh my
goodness
okay if it's the ski fall one i really
hope i make it through this time
i definitely like kicked over a chair
just now trying to get over there
it's okay fall guys can get you heated
you just become really invested and
really passionate
in your like macaroni character making
it through
or pale like character i don't even know
what to call
oh my goodness too good
i was so confident in that next jump too
oh oh is this like the slime run but
changed oh snap
tundra this one looks dangerous
i bet it's one of those like if you fall
you get permanently eliminated ones
right or maybe not
oh yeah it's an obstacle course one okay
easy now he got this i think oh maybe
not oh no no it's just a massive lift
over
there too oh i wonder if all those
things
okay no no no this one's fine i think
it's okay to fall
right
golf balls they look so painful
they're all shiny
easy flawless run let's go
oh that wasn't your fault that was that
guy's fault
[Music]
i thought that was gonna like send you
all the way over there okay
don't don't jump on that don't jump on
that don't jump
nice nice taking the highway i like it
ow it like bonked me okay there we go
all right looking good nice
good patience all right
this is crazy oh
[Applause]
no no oh okay
wait it only knocks me up oh do i have
to oh that's like is this like a timing
thing
yeah hey
okay okay let's go
oh this poor guy that was extremely
calculated
yep all planned
all right let's go let's go let's go
this game is so hard
[Laughter]
what's your favorite like finals map
like
like if you're going to the finals that
one yeah yeah that one's my favorite
the most stressful one is the tail one i
think
it is forever that one's just
stressful people are just chasing you
oh no i'm i'm not
good at this one i think you willed this
one into existence by thinking about it
last time
oh true true i kept thinking about this
okay
okay people be nice
one raven already fell off yeah i'm not
gonna take the shortcut because i'm just
not very good with the shortcuts in life
in general
okay there we go
boy nice nice we're in there
the patience the timing oh
oh
nice in
doing
there
nice save
i can't see myself
i can't see oh can't see okay okay
okay sir
so close so close
oh okay yeah that was greedy
i was pretty i was greedy i was crazy
[Laughter]
but if it would have worked it would
have been the greatest play of all of us
i'm so sad it's okay
i mean who wouldn't have went for it
let's be real timing person you know
if it's in front of me i'ma go for it
this game
super close super close i mean
yeah i should have gone through
it's okay santa has big ol beard in the
way
yeah he kind of clogged my way and then
because i started getting impatient
santa claus
yeah actually
okay this one this one's the one
agreed
i mean i kind of relate super hard to
the fall guys because
i'm pretty clumsy and sometimes my
character just falls over
and i can't get up i'm like i feel you
i'm so uncoordinated oh my goodness
actually i'm not very coordinated in
real life i'm more coordinated
in game and online
i tend to like crash into corners of
tables and
jam my toes into i don't know random
chair legs
yeah i actually you know but i'm not
that good either
i'm not much of an athlete
dude i really want this robo cat thing
oh it is
oh my god okay well he just bumped into
me that's cool
i take it back and cute yeah i'm cute
not cute not cute at all
okay no flow with the stream
flow with the river flow with the stream
like a fish
like a fish let me down oh
man okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay
no okay sir ponytail okay
no okay stop it okay
oh man there's a lot of people in front
of me come on
oh this is bad oh this is bad oh come on
[Applause]
i was wearing it there for a second no
no no no
that last hammer i had full faith
the frustrating thing about fall guys at
times is that other people's mess-ups
can just spill all over you
oh yeah and then you're just like well
well then
but i guess that's just life sometimes
stuff like that happens and you just
gotta keep going
it's true not everything's in your
control
but it's what you do with the situation
[Music]
oh here we go redemption time we got
this
time i mean just imagine how many other
people
don't know right we can't be the only
ones who didn't know
there's other people who don't know the
real objective of this one so
you know there has to be more people who
didn't read like us where it says jump
point
i believe all right
so i wonder if this the smaller ones are
worth more plants right
i don't know i just think like the
silver one is worth more
and then like the bull
ow the gold one is probably worth the
most
okay oh my god okay
i actually made it through the gold one
oh my god let's go nice no
oh i think we might have to use that
little
bouncy platform to get to the golden one
or the one in the center of the
maybe i don't know i got super cl
whoa i landed no no no no no stop it
this is cruel
so girls
yes let's go oh my god on this ski jump
one i
finally oh my god
oh no i'm not gonna make
it
[Music]
i think i can just slide into this one
without jumping okay
no n t and i got tin that time that's my
record
that one is definitely practice makes
perfect
just need more practice and it gets
easier
please don't be the memory one
oh no still have this one i'm so bad at
this
i just get destroyed by random like
banana or watermelon i'm chilling
in my own like pathway and then they
just fall on top of me
it's actually kind of insane how many
ninja skins there are also
oh my gosh so many ninja skins
oh okay that's oh that's a really really
really rough story
people just i feel like everyone got
destroyed right there so
okay okay get up wait wait no
banana
stop
that log okay oh nice dodge
all right we're in there
okay slowly but surely please
mr mingo sir i
oh my god that thing's going to fall on
me just no way
[Music]
there's like five people ahead of me yo
this
this one this one this one is so
this one makes me mad though this one
really makes me mad like
there's too many things that aren't in
my control other people
raining fruits the conveyor belt that's
against
me like there's just too many things
there's too many things that are in my
control
but you know what can be in your control
chat
super fast 5g and super low latency
from verizon that's where our stream is
sponsored by today
and you can lag less and play more by
visiting verizon.com
gaming so plug plug plug we're in there
and back to some follow guys action
your internet speed is something you can
control
for the most part all right i would love
to
exit this game ball guys so i can start
another one
yeah once you if you fail to exit during
that like
window you're just like sucked into the
next one
it's okay i have my watch everyone who
did better than you
know i have my feet on my desk
i am fully relaxed i okay i'm in my
gamer position
i got this nice it's nice i got this i
got this
all right i think we've officially
warmed up i'm feeling confident now in
my
as long as i don't get the ski one i
think i think we'll be okay
but if we do get the ski one then you've
got it no no you've got it to you
oh my god did you hear my stomach i hope
not
my stomach just grows so loud
oh
oh of course
if i still make it through after that i
will be amazed
yeah hold the ball for me hold the ball
please you flopping orange dino stop
[Music]
[Music]
there's so many names in front of me i'm
oh my god is this lag or is it just a
dino dude just missing me
oh oh no
this is not looking good perfect
because we got this we got this we got
this yeah
hold my wire
bless me
next up is
was that our first one yes
oh my god that felt like our second
okay okay
i know right neil in the chat said you
gave a head start and still
won the flex
wait we haven't done this one right um
no i don't think so actually
oh they actually added so many new game
modes okay okay
okay okay okay no no people stop pushing
me
i don't like being pushed oh
oh i see okay
well no pleasure
now this takes some patience yeah this
one
definitely takes place or if you're
coordinated and you can run on the
little ring oh i did it yeah
never been so happy to reach a
checkpoint oh my god my controller keeps
unplugging please stop
is it is it really not plugged in really
that's plugged in
oh my god this is going to be the bane
of my existence
all right well take those i touched a
checkpoint and then immediately
fluff my controller just keeps
disconnecting
it's due it's actually doomed oh my god
what's a jump button guys i don't
know i literally just walked off
oh my god my computer how's your
controller going
i just fixed it oh
this guy just pushed me off i don't
think i'm gonna make it
yeah i'm definitely not making it not
after
i literally stood in the center
so sad i like this one though
very doable
oh my god
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's okay
oh shoot
i'm honestly surprised this one is still
going oh yeah
i feel like i've taken 10 years just to
get halfway there we got it like there's
no wins
still go okay i fixed my controller
finally i hope i don't
okay okay this one this one's the run
this one's the one this one
i have one crown in my inventory but i
definitely
i don't know where it came from i think
like as you play
you just naturally unlock some crowns
nice
participation crown i like it yes
participate
i love that you could just add a couple
of wall time to your theme song and it's
automatically
it's like yes i feel the christmas
spirit yes
i love it i love the festive times
i can't believe christmas is only a
couple days away
oh i didn't even realize
[Laughter]
i didn't even realize like i knew that i
knew today was the 21st but i didn't
realize it was like a couple days
from christmas oh my goodness
yep this whole year is a blur happy
holidays everyone
happy holidays everyone
thanks for hanging with us yeah
honestly uh i should have put christmas
lights in my room
just so i feel festive all the time
maybe i still have time to do that it's
never too late
it really is never too late i kind of
want to do it
do it dude and you know if you go right
after
all the christmas lights and stuff will
be on sale probably
true i will carry
the festive spirit with me throughout
the rest of the month even if it's not
festive times
i mean once halloween ended it was
immediately christmas anyway
you kind of celebrate thanksgiving with
like
christmas spirit often
[Laughter]
did i do this one i failed oh yeah
oh my god look at traffic traffic this
are all god trafficking golf balls
okay people can't be nice
okay this is why we can't have nice legs
please don't punch
oh interesting okay
well you know that works i literally
okay
i didn't know i could do that that's
cool that's cool
um yeah i'm gonna take the highway i
guess
no
please yeah checkpoint
no the wind is strong
please come on like did you see me
okay people please
please
no i was so cold
i made it oh my god i made it 42. oh my
goodness
okay keep it alive for us
[Laughter]
oh my god i wish you saw how i made it
through after i got punched i i had a
very god gamer moment
oh my goodness
did it like push you up onto the side
yeah it pushed me up onto like the side
and i literally like
parkoured my way through on the fence
i was like i was like i was you know
freaking walking on a tight what what
are those called tight ropes
the tight rope yeah yeah
you were on the edge of glory yeah but
it would put it in the fence
instead you know if that was real life
though i would not be able to do that so
what my fall guys character is way more
agile than me agile agile i don't know
okay let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go we're on
the side little side with nice people
always always
is always a good thing it's always a
good thing oh [ __ ] i'm back on the side
of my people
okay okay to the left to the left
to the left to the left to the left on
platforms that people aren't on
on platforms people aren't on come here
ninja
you freaking cooperate with me
stop if i help you you're supposed to
help me
that's how life works
sabotage oh oh okay okay that one said
no to me that
that one just flat out rejected me it's
all good i can take a rejection
i'm really good at taking rejections
because you know taking rich action is
just like a part of life sometimes
okay it's true
okay okay take the patience pay is off
okay the patience does pay off
okay okay there we go okay
you know 14 out of 31 i still got time i
still got
a bit of time plenty of time okay
okay yo okay
ninja just work with me no no no no no
ninja you're gonna work with me okay
fine
see this is what happens
oh you're right there
i was so close it's all good
that guy just refused to cooperate with
me
and all right it's like dude i need you
to stand there and not
move forward we can do it together it's
even faster if we do it together
you know teamwork is only good if
everyone works together
otherwise people are just better off on
their own
but but teamwork is to make things
better
exactly it's okay this is this this is
the
actual final round you know at least
like once
i know i just want to see the crown i
don't
have to actually take it i just want to
see it
i've gotten this one quite a bit too
we've gotten this level quite a bit too
yeah we have
navigate the obstacles and race to the
finish line
we need star smitten voice over pack
added to fall guys immediately
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much
just you know when you grow up you feel
like you can do more
sometimes yeah exactly the extra
force of power everything my vocal
chords
[Laughter]
please be nice don't shoot a ball okay
thank you
ah
okay guys yeah yeah yeah we got this we
got this
i fell oh my lady there's so many names
in front of me
actually yeah there's so many people am
i even gonna i don't know
no oh oh god oh god oh god we're both
sucking where's
that corner oh we're going to make it
we're going to make it we're going to
make it work yeah
we're going to make it we're going to
make it oh my god let's go
oh let's go we were in that one together
[Music]
that corner was scary it really was
the anticipation i'm like pick the stage
which one is it
i feel like the ski one is is coming for
me
oh freezy peak we've never done this one
we have been interesting i
huh i noticed that we haven't done one
team yeah we've been doing a single team
i mean i'm not complaining though same
thing i'm not complaining i'm not
complaining
before uh we will it intuitive oh
scale the frozen mountain to reach the
finish line at the peak okay
sounds good sounds great it sounds
really
easy
am i gonna regret running straight up
this yes i am
fine
why did i do this oh this is like
almost really fun that was this game
does not like me
that was that was literally pointed at
me oh we go this way
oh okay oh snap okay we made it we made
it
i'm a horizon man this is easy
is that index oh no
i say as i completely fall off
i think the snowball got stuck here yeah
and i am
oh i'm kind of upside down can i please
be right side up
how do i become right side up well
that's not fair just flip me over
okay oh oh my god my controller
oh all right do you want to catch hands
on the right
i see i see i see
oh my lord
please please
please i want to ascend
yes no you're not
they're gatekeeping oh i made it
it was so close
[Music]
that was so close
dude the wind thing i was just upside
down
chilling and i was like well i'm i'm
stuck
why does it have to put me upside down
[Music]
curious oh my
i'll try my best this game just
penguin oh no oh my god this is
so cute look at the little bow ties oh
my god it's the first team game
oh okay okay team came all right you got
this you got this i believe in you and
your team
oh my god the little penguins there's
our penguins i want one
oh i see him they're so cute
how many penguins get the penguin
get the penguin is there only one oh no
there's multiple where are they all
wait your team's winning so much
wait how do i grab it oh my god
your team is on a roll you got this um
that's okay just like help your teammate
who's holding on to it
oh it's not holding on to it yeah yeah
yeah grab it grab it how do i pick it up
is it the same as grabbing oh yes the
same as grab excuse me
give me the penguin
no that's not it okay i'm gonna look for
another penguin
oh i want it
get over here oh gosh wow that red dude
is just hard carrying i don't know
oh my god oh my god it's so good okay
the tech to this is jumping okay the
tech to it is jumping
uh okay our guy got it now i gotta hold
the red dude
oh yeah pull the red dude pull the red
dude down pull them down
now get off my mirror oh no oh no
give me a penguin oh my god this guy's
insane
wait what did he get stuck on
stuck on like an imaginary
you guys just have to be not last just
not last just not last
just
[Music]
you guys got this you guys got this not
last not last
penguin yes yes take a dude
take it now give me give me a big i
just want to pet it one time
[Laughter]
yes i had it for one second i'm happy
all right
oh my god this has to be the final round
right
oh snap it has to be
has to be
has to be has to be
my heart's racing guys palms are sweaty
oh this one's new
oh okay we have the
eventually the ice break this is
definitely a final round
don't break the ice don't break the ice
look the crown the crown you got this
oh it's like the hexagon one but
more less jumpy
oh yeah i probably shouldn't be uh
running like this no no you stop it
right now
i am scared uh how many layers are like
four
i haven't i have no idea some people
have reached the bottom so
oh i know
you are so rude
i'm like it's good there's not a lot of
people around you
oh this guy's destroying everything
oh crap this one's like harder to get a
grasp of
where i am
oh no it was close it was just okay
okay okay it was close hey final round
finally final round
we saw it we saw it that was one goal we
did see it
all right one goal down the next goal is
weddings that means this
matches is it the winner right here yep
right here
this will be the whole one
and then you know if we have to end
stream i get
definitely adobe
guaranteed okay
chat's so generous are like nice try
that was hard
it was a really good try i mean you
didn't even know what the game mode
was like you know that was your first
time so
it was definitely interesting it's
nerve-wracking when you crack it
and you're like is it gonna is it gonna
crack all the way
yeah i was like trying to see what
happens if people stand on it
and just like chill but i think it
eventually breaks
yeah but again if everyone just
cooperated and didn't run around like
crazy it would also work out people
don't want to cooperate
ever i was already messing it up for
everyone i was just
okay you're doing what you what you
could to survive
i forgive you if it was hexagon that
would have worked
let's go i'm not very good
this one but it's all i think you
survived last time
oh did i actually yeah you got this
i remember i got flown all the way to
the back
i just whoa that was interesting
oh okay right smooth okay okay
okay
[Music]
oh no i don't want to be here
fan stop stop it's winter we don't need
fans here oh my goodness
oh okay i don't even notice those
logs you're totally right adding an
extra little grunt
definitely helps you jump further oh it
does
oh i'm just giving you my character back
scratch let's use that
oh oh oh nice
that's a really forgiving checkpoint
what the heck
oh shoot i mistimed that
people oh no
oh no i forgot there
i'm an idiot oh no no no you got this
you got it
if my math is correct you will be the
last person
please these top four spots four spots
[Laughter]
crap
you see the ice cream swirlies the one
on the bottom
i want an ice cream now i want like a
soft serve ice cream now
when's the last time you had a soft
serve ice cream like forever ago right
that's true it's been a really long time
because nobody has like a machine like
that in there
you know oh my god i wonder if there is
someone out there with a soft-serve ice
cream machine in their home
i'm sure there is and if so we need ice
cream
okay okay okay
oh now you get to watch how impatient i
am oh my goodness
now you've got this
cha are you ready to see the the world's
best run of gate crash
no performance five stars oh my god no
take notes it's happening oh no no
please don't take notes for i am
insanely engaging
flawless first jump from star smitten
flawless second jump she's calculating
her next path that's three flawless
jumps
oh my god okay okay i'm telling you guys
speed run
a hundred percent nice okay
okay okay okay okay no not that one
this one this one this one she
calculates the jump
let's
oh my goodness what did i tell you
clean run clean run let's go did you
guys take notes i hope you did
because it doesn't get much better than
that how about that
dude look at the robocat it's so cute i
want it
how chunky i want the cat ears
you put cat ears on anyone and all of a
sudden they just look so nice
sold it's just cat ears op
oh no oh
this is a make or break mode right here
yeah yeah yeah
i hope my team is full of winners i hope
my team works
you know we gotta be a well-oiled
machine
okay okay we be blue we're blue or blue
we got this
i i'm pushing people and not the ball
but it's all good
okay we got this okay we got this
oh [ __ ] oh shoot oh [ __ ] okay nice nice
nice nice
mess oh no my team's so good my team's
so good
nice nice you're doing better than
yellow team that's what's up
hey let's go oh no this yellow guy needs
to go home
it's okay we got this push push push
push guys push
i'm pushing i'm pushing look at me go
like oh i'm oh i'm not even pushing it
anymore oh yes yes we did it oh my god
we just okay
you know we ate that we really ate that
see that's what that yellow guy gets
for trying to gatekeep yup
lost his momentum on his own
okay okay
this is the ronald scott i hope so
flawless flawless run right here folks
please don't be the fruit shoot just
like anything but the fruit
because i have no chance with that one
okay okay okay okay okay okay
nice this is this is good okay i haven't
done this one in so long but you know
hopefully hopefully i i don't end this
okay people just be nice okay just be
nice oh my god they added
balls
they had oh the fruit they added fruit
to this i don't want to forget
this oh my goodness
okay okay you're alive i'm still okay
i'm still okay i'm still okay
good you're good
[Laughter]
oh god thank the lord oh dude
i as much as i love fruits i i don't
want them
crashing into me in games please no
[Laughter]
no no no no no oh god
are you serious there's like barely any
people oh my gosh
yeah there is fairly new people this is
gonna be oh no i'm yellow
represent a bit little penguin
little penguin oh there's a better one
yes
i think what's ours
i feel like that crying cat meme give a
big one back
[Music]
oh
yo this pink one's got them this
penguin's breaking ankles okay yeah
yellow team's got one
hey let's go no no no
yeah yeah yeah go go go get back here
your team is killing it right now let's
go
no no no no no let go
yeah red yellow you got this
all right you guys you brought honor and
glory to team yellow
and everything yeah yeah
oh my gosh all right let's get this done
okay let's get this done
oh my god
got this i believe oh god oh god oh god
wait they made this a final oh my god
i've never done this as a final round
exciting this is it this is oh god oh
god oh god
no people are gonna be grabbing me i
don't like
be nice be nice nice got this whole area
let's be nice everyone you know survive
survive together survive together
survive
survive
man this seems like a tough one for the
last one
everyone's being kind yeah yes to an
extent so far everyone's been kind of
nice
everyone's thinking the holiday spirit
you know
oh well please oh
my goodness it's nice safe oh my god
oh wow know
it's all good
the pressure got to be when it starts
speeding up
i started panicking i panicked i
panicked
that's all ahead it's all good we've had
some fun games
we almost had the crown totally fine um
are there any last words you have for
the viewers for today's stream
happy holidays yes
absolutely happy holidays i get
that today's stream was sponsored by
verizon with super fast 5g and super low
latency
you can lag less and play more of course
if you guys want to learn more then you
can go to verizon.com
gaming thank you so much for tuning in
today it was a blast
and we will see you guys next time see
you later bye guys
you